our sun looks nothing like this it looks
more like
this if you've always thought our sun
was a bright yellow ball of fire you
were wrong for starters it's not yellow
it's
green sort
of scientists determine the temperature
of a star by the color spectrum it emits
each color has its own wavelength and
Astron measure those wavelengths to tell
how hot a star is cooler stars appear
red the hottest of the stars look
blue our sun emits most of its energy at
a wavelength that's close to
Green but because it also emits other
wavelengths all these colors mix
together and your eyes see this vibrant
mixture as white that is if you look at
the Sun from the International Space
Station from here on Earth the the sun
looks yellow because our atmosphere is
really good at scattering blue light and
with all that blue wavelength gone all
the other colors combine into yellow if
our star was actually yellow it would be
about 800° C cooler our Solar System's
habitable zone would shrink and Earth
would become a frozen lifeless
Rock but that's not the only thing you
were wrong
about the Sun is hot but it's not on
fire burning is a chemical reaction of
oxygen with
fuel like most stars out there our sun
is a ball of gas mostly made up of
hydrogen and helium it doesn't have much
oxygen in it instead it works more like
a gigantic nuclear reactor constantly
fusing hydrogen atoms to create helium
inside its core this process releases
enormous amounts of energy and that's
why the sun is so scorching hot speaking
of setting things on fire let me tell
you about explosions in space yeah these
aren't real a spaceship can't go down in
a violent blast because there's no air
out there in space No Air means no
oxygen and no oxygen well as you already
know means no fire sorry star Wars
fans it may seem that there are too many
stars in the night sky for you to count
but actually you can although scientists
at Harvard have already done it for you
according to the Yale bright star
catalog there are
9,110 stars that you can see from Earth
with the naked eye try to count them all
for
yourself movies make it look like you
need to be an extremely skilled pilot to
navigate the asteroid belt but
that's not true the asteroid belt isn't
some thick obstacle course of death it
does have trillions of space rocks that
range in size from space dust to a
quarter the size of the Moon about
100,000 of these asteroids are over 1 km
wide but they're very spread
out the asteroid belt between Mars and
Jupiter is
225 million kilm across
that's one and a half times the distance
between Earth and the
Sun and this spreads the space rocks
millions of kilometers apart it's almost
impossible for a spacecraft to collide
with one if you were thrown out of the
airlock into the vastness of space you
wouldn't turn into a popsicle right away
that's because to freeze there has to be
a heat transfer from space to your body
but heat or cold cold doesn't travel
very fast in the vacuum of space your
body would freeze but it would take
hours to happen and by then you'd be
long dead from something else and no you
wouldn't explode in space either you
would inflate though that's because
nitrogen and your bloodstream would
gather into bubbles and puff you up to
double your size but that's not what's
going to kill you it's the lack of
oxygen after 15 seconds in space your
brain wouldn't get enough oxygen through
your blood and you'd lose
Consciousness after 2 minutes in space
your other organs would start to shut
down one by
one game
over space seems incredibly cold but
it's not in reality space doesn't
doesn't have a temperature at all
temperature is defined by the speed at
which particles move and the amount of
energy they have in the true vacuum of
space there are no particles to move
around that's why the vacuum is
temperatur L of course outer space isn't
a perfect vacuum it still has particles
and radiation to produce heat some areas
of space are actually really hot like
the space around
stars but the further away you get from
Stars the more spread out the particles
are making those areas of space pretty
chilly some dense gas clouds can get as
cold as-
263°
cus Mercury is the closest planet to the
Sun but surprisingly it's not the
hottest it is Extreme though during the
day the surface temperature reaches 4
30° and at night it drops to-
180 but the most hellish planet in the
solar system is Venus you see Mercury
doesn't have an atmosphere to retain all
that heat from the Sun the venusian
atmosphere on the other hand is very
thick and it creates a greenhouse effect
it's like global warming on
steroids and it makes Venus a hot hell
with a surface temperature of about
475° our entire solar system isn't just
sitting in one spot in our galaxy it's
hurdling through space at 220 km/ second
that's seven times faster than the speed
that Earth revolves around the Sun our
solar system takes 230 million years to
make one orbit around the Milky Way yeah
the last time we were in the same
location we are now Earth had one super
continent and the dinosaurs were just
starting to roam around planets do not
orbit around the sun all the things in
our solar system are in balance and even
though the sun is the most massive
object in our planetary neighborhood
other planets are participating in this
gravitational tug of
war instead of orbiting the Sun planets
and moons orbit around a central point
between them and our star this point is
called the Berry Center for Earth this
Berry Center is so close to the sun's
core that there's not much of a
difference but for Jupiter this point is
about 55,000 km away from the center of
the Sun so the gas giant and the sun are
orbiting each other
Earth appears round from space but it's
actually an irregularly shaped
ellipsoid it bulges at the equator
thanks to the centrifugal force caused
by our planet's spin as a result Earth
is about 43 km wider at the equator than
it is at the poles this makes gravity at
the Bulge slightly weaker making it
easier to launch spaceships from the
equatorial regions than from the
poles in space no one can hear you
scream that's only true to a point sound
needs a medium to travel through and in
space molecules are very far apart so
the sound Fades away before it can get
very far all the cosmic catastrophes
supernovas and colliding black holes go
quiet before you can hear them but some
places in space have a a lot of
particles for sound to travel through
like the hot gas cloud around the black
hole at the center of the pereus Galaxy
cluster it has so much gas that you can
actually hear the black hole this is
what it sounds
like if the Earth had an edge I hope it
would look like
this the edge of a flat Earth
I know I know we've talked about it
before but there's something mesmerizing
about it a flat Earth Solar Eclipse
diagonally growing
trees the Great Wall of ice guarded by
NASA of
course the flat earthers sure have a
great imagination but what if they were
right how would the Earth hold up in
space would it revolve around the Sun or
would the Sun rotate around
it and why would you never walk to the
Earth's
Edge this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Earth was
flat in case you missed the news on the
Flat Earth Channel here's a quick recap
for thousands of years the general
public thought that the Earth was flat
and everything revolved around it then
Nicolas Copernicus came around with his
spanking new Theory the theory said that
the Earth wasn't flat and definitely not
the center of anything his observations
led him to believe that our planet is
orbiting the
Sun but here we are 500 years later and
some people around the globe are
convinced that the the Earth is flat
well how would this even
work do you know why the planets form in
a spherical shape one word
gravity gravity is what's pulling matter
together equally from every side and as
a result matter forms into a sphere of
course this wouldn't be the case for a
flat
earth anti- round earthers think that
there's no such thing as Gra gra it we
only feel like there is because some
mysterious force is accelerating the
pancake shaped Earth upwards I don't
need to tell you that you can't increase
the speed Forever at some point you'd be
going too
fast G does anybody feel like a burnt
pancake
no if you want some real science then
yes there would be gravity on a flat
Earth and it would be
weird the center of gravity on a flat
Earth would be right here in the middle
everything on Earth and around would be
pulled to this point and the further you
got away from the center the stronger
this pull would
be at some point it would begin to pull
you downward so you would have to start
climbing this would be the reason why
you couldn't walk to the edge of a flat
Earth gravity would be so strong around
there that it would be impossible for
you to make it you might never see the
gorgeous 45 M tall wall of ice called
Antarctica Guard railing the Earth's
Edge and you'd never learn what's on the
flip side but at least you wouldn't fall
off of it there would be other side
effects of this funny gravity objects
closer to the edge of the Earth would
fall sideways instead of down
gravity would also make trees grow
diagonally on most of the pancake leg
Earth because they'd be reaching against
the pull of
gravity all the rain snow and hail would
fall toward the Arctic at the center of
the earth the precipitation would
converge and start to build up the
oceans would get sucked to the center of
the disc too and form one big ocean in
the
middle a big concern would be the air
pressure on a flat
Earth gravity would draw too much air
toward the Earth's center leaving the
areas around the edge with no air
pressure at
all that would be bad because people
living in a flat Earth Australia
wouldn't have enough oxygen to breathe
and if you lived closer to the Middle
where the Arctic would be you'd be
crushed by the weight of the
atmosphere but not for long
a flat Earth wouldn't have a geomagnetic
field around it this field is generated
by the movements of the Earth's core and
well a flat Earth just wouldn't have one
nothing would be holding our atmosphere
in place and eventually it would spill
into space we'd be exposed to solar
radiation that would cause cancer and
damage our DNA and we'd have no
breathable air anywhere on the planet so
I hope you're able to find a life
support system lying
around now let's get to those questions
we've all been waiting
for what would orbit what in this
Arrangement would there be a day and
night cycle or time
zones every flat earther knows that the
Sun goes in circles around a pancake
shaped Earth and so does the moon
they're both around 50 km in diameter
and act like huge
spotlights but let's bring good old
science to the
equation if the sun worked as a
spotlight you'd see it from everywhere
on Earth even if it didn't shine
directly on
you it would look like those alien
abduction scenes hm I wonder where they
got that idea
from in this system there would be no
day and night cycle
that would be pretty strange am I
supposed to get my beauty
sleep okay I know how to fix
this yeah that's better for a flat Earth
to have days alternating with nights the
sun would have to orbit the planet this
way when the sun was up the entire
planet of Earth would experience
daylight and when the sun went down the
Earth would fall into
nighttime there would be no time zone
and no Seasons either but you could
still mess up your schedule by staying
up late and watching what if
videos you'd be lucky if the sun was so
much smaller than the earth sort
of think of this if the sun retained its
gigantic form as it was orbiting a flat
Earth it would burn down the entire
planet that's because of how close it
would get to
us on the other hand if the sun were
much smaller than it really is we'd
freeze to death that's because the Flat
Earth would have nearly 2 and 1 half
times the surface area of our round
earth we'd be getting only one3 of a
regularized sun's energy that's not
enough for life on a flat Earth to
exist and we haven't even talked about
this yet the lunar eclipse
Flat Earth disciples believe in some
kind of antimoon that's responsible for
these on our round earth lunar eclipses
happen when the earth lines up between
the Sun and the Moon if that was the
case for a flat Earth this is how those
eclipses might look and even that would
require some very special
alignment so if the Flat Earth
conspiracy turned out to be true that
our Globe was indeed photoshopped and
GPS devices were rigged for some
financial gain well that would open up a
conversation to other conspiracy
theories unfortunately many people
including the flat earthers are living
in a state of cognitive dissonance
that's when their thoughts and beliefs
aren't quite consistent and don't always
represent
reality I mean we are constantly exposed
to pseudo evidence that can support any
Theory at all even if it falls flat with
a bit of logical
thinking if kernus had spent 10 hours on
YouTube watching Flat Earth conspiracy
videos even he might have admitted he
was
wrong when you think of ringed planets
well you probably assume there's only
one of them in our solar system Saturn
but what if I told you that there are
three other planets similar to Saturn
yeah it's true Jupiter Uranus and
Neptune all have their own sets of
rings most people don't know about them
because they're much thinner and pretty
much invisible from Earth we only
learned about them when Voyager 1 and
Voyager 2 flew past them in the 1970s
and 80s some scientists even think that
Earth had rings at some point in its
existence 4 and2 billion years ago when
a planet that the size of Mars smashed
into our young rock it ejected so much
debris that it likely briefly formed a
small ring around
Earth despite their unimaginably massive
gravitational pull black holes don't go
around sucking in everything in their
way it just doesn't work like that black
holes are more like sink holes if you
were to get too close to one you'd get
spaghettified and lost to the Blackness
of this monstrosity but if you're far
enough away from it you'd be safe even
if our sun was replaced in the middle of
our solar system by a black hole with
similar mass all the planets would just
orbit like nothing happened things would
get pretty dark
though now speaking of Darkness the moon
doesn't have a dark side our planetary
partner gets hit by the sunlight all
around the reason why you don't see the
other side of the moon is because it's
always facing away from us yeah our moon
rotates on its axis at the same rate it
orbits Earth making it what's called
tidily locked to our
planet if a large asteroid is on a
deadly Collision Course with Earth the
best thing to do is to Nuke
it oh sorry wait I've actually got that
wrong
do not nuke asteroids that are about to
collide with us the reason why well
because the nuclear explosion will
shatter the asteroid into millions of
smaller pieces yeah the pieces that
would still be headed for impact with
us instead of dealing with just one
giant asteroid we'd have to deal with
multiple impacts and it would make our
evacuation really difficult or straight
up
impossible now you still can use a nuke
to prevent an asteroid Collision but you
don't even have to strike the space Rock
we just set off a nuke near the asteroid
emphasis on
near then the force from the blast would
nudge it off course and that would keep
our planet safe
hopefully standing on Earth at night you
can see thousands of stars but the view
from the Moon is actually quite
boring yeah astronauts who traveled to
the Moon reported that stars aren't
easily visible from there because our
moon is super reflective it really
cranks up the brightness making it
harder to see out to the Stars it's kind
of like stargazing in a city with a lot
of light pollution not fun you'd need to
travel further into space to get some
better views
traveling in space won't make you taller
though it's true that astronauts can
grow up to 5 cenm in space well that's
because the Earth's gravity doesn't
weigh them down and the vertebrae and
their spines are able to expand a bit
but this effect is only temporary as
soon as you return to Earth you get back
to your regular height yeah thanks
gravity and space travel doesn't make
you age slower either not really Albert
Einstein theorized that time would pass
slower for someone traveling at high
speeds versus for someone stationary
this is called time dilation and while
it's true you'd have to travel
incredibly fast to achieve this de-aging
effect like almost speed of light fast
yeah with our current space traveling
technology the difference in time is so
minimal that it's not even worth
calculating
if you thought crying in space was
impossible well first why and second
you're wrong it's just different without
gravity to pull your tears down they
don't trickle down your face like they
do here on Earth the tears just stick to
your eyes and form a sort of watery blob
they might even cover your eyes if you
cry a lot so while you can totally cry
in space it's probably best that you
don't not great for
visibility hey Martian dust storms are a
real headache the dust particles are so
fine that they can get anywhere and
these dust storms can last for months
but they can't physically damage any
equipment that we leave on the red
planet the thing is is that the Martian
atmosphere is super thin just about 1%
of the atmosphere we have on Earth so
even when these dust partic Zoom around
at about 100
kmph they can't pack a big punch without
the help of air but what they can do is
cover our solar panels and put our
Rovers into power saving
hibernation oh and I wouldn't inhale
this dust either who knows what this
fine powder could do to your lungs long
term twinkle twinkle little star how I
wonder what you are up above the world
so high this song is a big fat
lie yeah despite the famous children's
song Stars don't twinkle the flickering
is Just an Illusion their light is
actually very steady stars appear to
twinkle due to the gas molecules that
make up our atmosphere they deflect some
of the light from Stars making them
appear as if they're
shimmering asteroid belts are typically
depicted as minefields of floating rocks
spaceships have to weave in and out of
the asteroids in a life or death
situation but in reality our asteroid
belts are nothing like what you see in
the movies asteroids aren't that close
together in fact they're extremely far
apart for example in the asteroid belt
between Jupiter and Mars each of the
asteroids is several million kilomet
away from their nearest neighbor and the
chances of a collision are about 1 in
one billion so while Han chewy and Leia
had you on the edge of your seat and The
Empire Strikes Back asteroid Fields like
that are Far From
Reality the Great Wall of China is known
to be the only man-made object that's
visible from space but this is entirely
false yeah sure maybe you could see it
with a camera and a zoom lens but it's
almost invisible to the naked eye at 5 5
to 10 m wide the wall is way too thin to
be seen from space however you can still
see plenty of other man-made objects
from space things like dams Bridges and
pyramids and at night you can see a
light show from the world's big
cities did you know that there's a
mysterious area in space where
astronauts are unable to communicate
with home base they're exposed to
extreme levels of radiation and their
spaceships start to malfunction it's
being dubbed the Bermuda Triangle of
space this area has perplexed scientists
for decades but astronomers may have
finally solved this outer space
anomaly what exactly is the Bermuda
Triangle of space anyway well its
official name is the South Atlantic
anomaly or SAA for short it's hovering
above the South Atlantic stretching from
Chile to Zimbabwe and this area has a
considerably weaker magnetic field when
compared to the rest of the Van Allen
radiation belt the Van Allen radiation
belt is a pair of cosmic Donuts
surrounding Earth this is a unique
location where the radiation belt comes
closest to the Earth's surface these
belts trap particles that shoot from the
sun which protects the Earth from
harmful radiation the solar radiation
within the South Atlantic anomaly
isn't held back to the same degree
though but why well to explain that
first let's dive into what happens if
you wander into this terrifying part of
our solar system the SAA is known for
causing electronic malfunctions in
spaceships and extreme radiation
exposure for astronauts it can
completely destroy spacecraft in 2016
the Japanese satellite Hitomi Came
Crashing Down to Earth after satellite
operators began getting mixed signals
from the ship it was reporting
inaccurate data about how it was
performing up in space making people
down on Earth think that everything was
fine but this was happening as it
traveled through the SAA so operators
weren't aware that there was a problem
and couldn't take steps to correct it
the Hubble telescope luckily has managed
to avoid any issues while traveling
through the SAA that's despite spending
a whopping 15% of its time in the space
anomaly to protect the telescope
satellite operators power it down if
they didn't the SAA could corrupt any
precious data that's being collected and
potentially crash but how do astronauts
deal with these heavy levels of
radiation well their radiation levels
are constantly being monitored so if
they do end up in the anomaly they have
what's known as a water wall certain
rooms on ships are filled with these
massive bags of water and if you stand
behind them they'll protect you from
radiation water is the best thing to
Shield you from this harmful energy
because of its high hydrogen content now
if they didn't have this water wall they
could get severe radiation poisoning or
even cancer so we know the radiation
levels are much higher and more
dangerous in this specific part of space
but why is it happening in the first
place well despite what pictures might
show you Earth isn't completely round it
bulges around the center like me and
because of this the Earth's physical
Center and its magnetic Center are
slightly off by about 500 km this offset
means things like cosmic rays can get
closer to the Earth's surface near the
bulging area luckily the Earth's
magnetic bubble can still keep all those
dangerous rays from getting to us but
that's not the case for people in space
above the South Atlantic because of this
stronger radiation levels can reach this
point up in space and what's even more
concerning due to the fact that the
magnetic poles here on Earth are
constantly changing the South Atlantic
anomaly keeps growing it's also gotten
weaker by 15% meaning the radiation has
gotten stronger in the area so NASA has
been carefully monitoring the SAA since
2019 they've noticed that the anomaly is
moving West and what's even weirder the
anomaly is also splitting in two if this
continues it could make things even more
comp licated regarding space travel and
data collection but luckily for it to
change significantly would take Millions
if not billions of
years so this Bermuda Triangle of space
isn't as mysterious as it sounds and
astronomers are getting better at
handling it with every new ship launch
and every piece of data
recorded no that's not
Photoshop that's an actual video from
the inter International Space Station of
the Moon looking a bit
squished wow so what happened here is
the cover up behind a flat Moon an
elaborate government
conspiracy how would this affect the
oceans what would happen to our
climate and could the moon fly out into
space this is what it
and here's what would happen if the Moon
was
flat in 2010 an astronaut on the
International Space Station observed a
bizarre phenomenon when he glanced out
the window he saw the Moon looked
flattened when it appeared in the
thickest part of the Earth's atmosphere
and those of you in the Flat Earth
Society don't at me it's not
flat high above the planet the air bends
light to give the moon this squished
look in these very specific
conditions but if the moon were flat it
would explain why we never see the
mysterious dark side and if this was our
reality how would this affect gravity on
Earth okay there are no Illusions this
time the moon is flat so how would that
happen
well a Celestial body would need to spin
incredibly fast to become a flat disc so
fast that it would rip into tiny pieces
before it would ever have a chance to
form for our purposes let's say the moon
survived this process and formed like a
plate would this flat moon have the same
mass as what we see right now well as a
flat disc the moon could have 25% of the
thickness but the width might remain the
same with so much less Mass floating
above the Earth the change in Ocean
Tides could be the first noticeable
effect the moon's gravitational pull
generates these Tides our moon pulls the
water on the side of the earth that's
closest to it but this flat Moon would
have less mass and less gravitational
effect on our planet and the altered
Tides would affect more than just
Surfers ocean tides stir up material
below the water's surface allowing
Coastal ecosystems to thrive without the
usual strong waves animal life in the
oceans like crabs muscles and snails
could die off in Mass numbers this Chain
Reaction could decimate life
worldwide and that's not all a flat Moon
would ruin remember the tide es also
push water back and forth around the
planet when warm Waters travel from one
area to another these tidal forces
change weather patterns globally without
the strong Tides we could experience
extreme temperature changes but even
with all these devastating changes the
climate still wouldn't change as fast as
the days the moon's Mass influences our
planet's rotation
giving us a 24-hour day but with a flat
Moon the day could be only 15 hours long
but I think most of us could live with a
5-hour
workday and while we'd get more sunlight
the nights would be even darker you see
the Moon reflects the sunlight to give
off that bright glow we all know and
love a smaller Moon would reflect less
light making it much dimmer that would
make it harder for nocturnal animals
that rely on the moon for navigation and
hunting but maybe none of that would
matter since it could potentially crash
right into
us wait
what yeah the Earth and the moon are
locked together in an eternal dance the
motion created by one affects the other
I know this sounds hippie dippy but
trust me we're talking science here the
same tidal forces that move the oceans
also affect the moon's orbit the tidal
bulges in the ocean rotate faster than
the moon orbits the earth and this
rotation takes energy away from the
earth and transfers that into the moon's
orbit this is called tidal friction and
causes the moon to drift away from us at
the rate of 3 82 CM every year a flat
moon with less Mass would orbit closer
to our planet so maybe it wouldn't slam
into Earth but our view of celestial
phenomena wouldn't be the same right now
the Sun and Moon are positioned just
perfectly that when aligned we get a
spectacular image of a total eclipse on
Earth the moon covers the sun entirely
in this breathtaking event a squished
Moon wouldn't be able to block out the
sun entirely during an eclipse and we
would see the top and bottom of the sun
peeking out a flat Moon could destroy
the balance of life on Earth and
threatens every ecosystem and living
organism including
humans billions of years ago another
planet smashed into Earth
an event of this epicness could have
created our moon it also could have
brought alien life to our
planet what evidence of this planet
still exists on Earth
today could there be life deep inside
the Earth's
surface and could that life be an
advanced civilization of humanoid
aliens this is what if and here's what
would happen if aliens are living inside
the
earth 4 and a half billion years ago
Thea a protoplanet the size of Mars
struck our young Earth this Collision
scattered pieces of both planets into
space and many scientists argue that
these pieces eventually coalesced into
our
moon but what happened to the rest of
Thea is still a
mystery the existence of blobs of
material inside Earth's mantle known as
low Shear velocity provinces could be
evidence that parts of Thea fused with
Earth these chunks are up to 1,000 km in
height and several times that in width
they sit below Africa and the Pacific
Ocean straddling Earth's core like a
pair of headphones
but other theories some dating back
centuries suggest a completely different
explanation of what exists under the
surface a lush tropical Paradise for
aliens the Earth consists of four layers
the crust the mantle and the outer and
inner core but there hasn't been any
successful exploration below the crust
so there's much we don't know about the
reality ities below the surface this has
led to spectacular speculation like the
hollow Earth theory according to this
Theory our planet could be a series of
nested spheres centered around a central
core in between these shells atmospheres
could exist that are capable of
supporting life in the 17th century
Edmund hi the scientist who discovered
Hal's Comet backed this Theory many
others have added to it suggesting a
small Sun could be hanging in the center
of the earth and plants animals and
humans could be living there and not
just humans but a race of
superhumans Immortals who possess
sophisticated technology to build
hundreds of subterranean cities but if
there were aliens inside the earth what
would the conditions for life be could
the inside of our planet be a luscious
Paradise or a hot hellish
dump if you were to visit one of the low
sheer velocity provinces you'd have to
go 2900 km below the
surface here you'd be surrounded by
magma or liquid rock with temperatures
as high as
37°
C and the weight of the crust and mantle
above you would increase the pressure to
over
237,000 times the atmospheric pressure
you know on the surface of the
Earth whatever life you find here would
need to exist in these extreme
conditions and these life forms would
need to evolve to extract oxygen
directly from the magma or live without
it they'd need to survive without any
sunlight radiation would be the primary
energy source and lucky for them the
radioactive decay of uranium thorium and
potassium in the Earth's crust and
mantle already account for the primary
source of heat in the Earth's
interior there could be all kinds of
undiscovered creatures down there but
until you could withstand the pressure
and heat to find out we'll never
know and as for the hollow Earth well
it's nice to imagine a paradise World
underneath our feet instead of layers
upon layers of hot molten
[Music]
rock just north of the Martian equator
lies a 45 km wide impact CR at that
scientists believe may have been the
sight of an ancient Lake here at jazero
Crater scientists theorize that its
frozen soil may contain the most
significant discovery of
humankind
life on February 18th
2021 NASA's perseverance Rover started
searching this crater to find out if
we're truly
alone what is the likelihood of Life on
Mars what would these Martians look
like and how will we send samples back
to
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if we discovered Life on
Mars as Scientific American puts it it
would take a near miracle for Mars to be
sterile astrobiologist Chris McKay at
Nasa believes that Earth and Mars have
been sharing materials for billions of
years kind of like using your roommates
spice rack what I thought you said it
was
communal comets or large meteorites that
have hit Earth may have also sent debris
onto Mars a tiny fraction of this debris
on Mars could have carried the same
microbes that kickstarted Life as we
know it on Earth but what would this
alien life look
like many scientists agree that whatever
life on Mars we might find would need to
be incredibly robust with the
combination of radiation and freezing
temperatures on Mars could any life form
survive such a harsh
environment as far-fetched as it sounds
microbiologists have discovered many
organisms that thrive in extreme
environments the tardigrade or water
bear is a highly resistant extrem aile
it can withstand heat cold pressure
radiation and even a complete lack of
oxygen there are also certain types of
bacteria on Earth that rapidly produce
spores when faced with hazardous
conditions the bacteria can then
hibernate during an extended period of
drought
withstand intense ionizing radiation a
team of 1,000 geologists chemists
physicists and biologists worldwide have
drilled 4.8 km into the Earth and
discovered robust life forms Mars has a
similar geological past to Earth so
looking underground could be a great
place to
start by drilling into the Jero crater
we could encounter spores associated
with with a relatively recent geological
era and on future missions to Mars we
may dig deeper and uncover fully
vegetative
microbes to find rock samples that might
support life NASA's perseverance Rover
uses an array of lasers called a super
cam it can study the surface of Mars at
a distance one of the lasers will heat a
rock sample and vaporize it this creates
a plasma that can be analyzed to
understand its Elemental composition
another laser will reveal which
compounds are in the dirt if the super
cam detects organic molecules or
elevated concentrations of elements like
nitrogen or phosphorus the Rover will
head over to take a closer look it will
then scan the soil in Greater detail to
detect any organic material hiding in
the
dirt NASA's team on Earth has only one
shot at picking the right spot to gather
these samples with limited space on
board the Rover only a few dozen samples
can be collected so no pressure and
fingers
crossed if all goes well NASA plans to
bring back samples known for preserving
bio signatures on Earth bio signatures
are faint molecular traces left behind
by microbes billions of years ago once
the samples are collected NASA and the
European Space Agency plan two missions
to get them back to Earth this involves
blasting tubes of rock and soil samples
into orbit to be collected by another
spacecraft and then return to Earth wa
this looks kind of
fun if perseverance is mission is
successful the discovery of Life on Mars
would be as groundbreaking as the
discovery of
DNA in
1543 Copernicus boldly shook the status
quo with his theory that the planets
orbited the sun his discoveries
completely changed our worldview no
longer putting Earth at the center of
the
universe discovering life beyond Earth
could be just as
powerful but not finding any life could
raise more questions is the earth truly
special
are we alone out
here even if we don't discover Life
these Martian Rock samples will allow
chemists to study the geochemistry
minerology and foundational Bedrock
materials of Mars in
detail this could provide us with
essential insights into the climate
history of Mars and help us better
understand earth's climate as
well in
1976 two Viking Land sers became the
first spacecrafts from Earth to touch
down on Mars they too probed for life in
the Martian soil and the results are
still debated to this day one experiment
indicated that the Martian soil tested
positive for
metabolism on Earth this would almost
certainly suggest the presence of life
but another related experiment found no
trace of organic material
whatsoever While most scientists have
not reconciled the conflicting results
the consensus is that there's no
conclusive evidence of Life on Mars but
several researchers disagree recent
discoveries of terrestrial
microorganisms surviving outside of the
ISS indicate that life may be resilient
enough for Mars and methane in the
Martian atmosphere could be a sign of
microbial
methanogens a type of microorganism that
produces a significant amount of methane
stinky
aliens mind you it's possible that life
on Mars didn't have the right conditions
to start at all or maybe it died off
from an Extinction event similar to the
asteroid that wiped out the dinosaurs or
it's even possible that we might end up
finding life that was accidentally
brought to Mars by one of our many
Rovers
let's hope this perseverance Mission
doesn't turn into a $2.7 billion face
palm if Mars is your bag well have you
ever thought about setting up shop there
with recent developments in
rocketry colonizing Mars might be
possible In Our
Lifetime you better strap in because
that's a story for another what
if
our sun looks nothing like this it looks
more like
this if you've always thought